à 50 euros nash est ce un clip qui
irrite euros chacun pas de repos même le
mercredi après midi pour ses enfants de
villiers le bel
à l'heure où la plupart de leurs
camarades s'amuser jouent eux sont en
plein renforcement scolaire y en a qui
sont très très fort en français mais
alors en mathématiques que c'est leur
bête noire
on y arrive fort bah justement on va
valoriser ce qu'il sait et lui même il
viendra aider quelqu'un qui aura des
difficultés en mathématiques
enfin en français par contre il
travaillera c'est mathématique et il
verra que ce n'est ce n'est pas un
monstre et qu'on peut le vaincre vaincre
le monstre des mathématiques ou du
français s'est donc l'ambition de ces
ateliers
pour y parvenir le travail était
essentielle le cadre aussi asseyez-vous
merci
c'est des règles qui qui leur permettent
déjà de ceux de se valoriser eux mêmes
nous sommes quelqu'un je ne suis pas
n'importe qui ils sont accueillis un
parent c'est c'est un accueil individuel
avec tout le respect qui se doit des
règles mais aussi de la bienveillance à
l'heure du goûter les enfants sont
invités à prendre la parole pour
dévoiler leur meilleure note
s'il vous plaît vous ont écouté écouter
les g1 très bien en français pour aider
ces enfants issus de milieux sociaux
fragile l'association peut s'appuyer sur
un réseau d'une cinquantaine de
bénévoles
elle bénéficie également depuis deux ans
des fonds européens et 47 mille euros en
tout devenu essentiel pour son activité
actuellement nous savons plus de 215
inscrits et qui suivent le programme
au sein de notre association et on n'a
plus de sens en attente
si l'action est renouvelée si les fonds
se renouveler ça nous permettra de
pouvoir donner la chance aux autres
quoi qu'il arrive le pdh poursuivra son
activité en faveur des écoliers avec
toujours une seule et même ambition
depuis ses débuts
les épées des absents côté des mrc
[Applaudissements]